>> ♪ ♪
>> NOW FOR A SPECIAL
THANKSGIVING STREET.
THE MOVING CONCLUSION OF MY
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH ACTOR
JON VOIGHT FROM HIS FIRST
SURPRISE ISSING ROLE ON
BROADWAY.
A GOLDEN GLOBE WINNING
PERFORMANCE ON TV'S RAY DONOVAN.
>> I WAS SURPRISEED TO LEARN IN
1961 JON VOIGHT WAS IN THE
ORIGINAL PRODUCTION OF THE SOUND
OF MUSIC.
>> I FILLED IN.
I WAS THE FIRST REPLACEMENT.
>> WOW.
>> I GOT TO WORK 2 WEEKS WITH
MARY MARTIN WHO WAS FANTASTIC.
I ASSUMED AFTER 2 YEARS SHE WAS
JUST PHONING IT IN.
SHE WASN'T.
SHE WAS A GREAT LISTENER.
WHEN I WAS ON STAGE WITH HER,
SHE WAS LISTENING TO ME.
SHE WAS RESPONDING TO ME.
I WAS QUITE SURPRISED.
THE FIRST NOTE I GOT, AFTER MY
FIRST PERFORMANCE, I WAS VERY
GOOD IN THAT PERFORMANCE.
THE ENERGY WAS HIGH.
THE ADRENALINE WAS WORKING.
I GAVE A PRETTY GOOD
PERFORMANCE.
I GOT ONE NOTE.
IT SAID DON'T UPSTAGE MISS
MARTIN.
>> IN 1978 YOU WON AN OSCAR FOR
COMING HOME" WHICH CAPTURED EYE
VIETNAM VET WHO WAS PARALYZED.
WHAT CHANGED IN YOU?
DID IT SENSITIZE YOU FROM THE
SOLDIERS COMING HOME FROM
VIETNAM?
>> I WAS A LIBERAL BUT I WAS IN
TRANSITION.
I WAS SHOCKED.
VIETNAM CELEBRATED THAT AS A
VICTORY.
YOU ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE HORROR THAT WAS CREATED WHEN
OUR PULLING OUT.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN A
SPINAL CORD INJURY PLACE.
I SPENT THE NIGHT.
IN SOME OF THE ROOMS AND HEARD
THE VOICES AND SOME OF THE MOANS
AND STUFF OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAD
THESE INJURIES.
THEIR SUFFERING WAS WHAT I WAS
SUPPOSED TO PORTRAY.
I WAS TRYING TO GET THIS RIGHT
FOR THESE GUYS.
>> YOU DID.
>> I JUST HAD THIS ACCIDENT WITH
THE HELICOPTER.
IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT TOOK YOU
OUT TO DOVER TO RECEIVE THE
BODDOS OF THE SOLDIERS?
>> RIGHT.
HE FELT I HAD EMPATHY FOR THE
FAMILIES AND INVITED ME.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME?
YES, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
CEREMONY PERFORMED AND SAY MY
PRAYERS AND SALUTE THOSE
CASKETS.
>> THE CEREMONY, THERE IS AN ART
TO IT.
I WAS SO GRATEFUL TO BE THERE.
>> IT'S AN INCREDIBLE THING TO
WITNESS.
>> THAT RITUAL, THAT ART MADE
THE STATEMENT OF OUR RESPECT AND
OUR GRATITUDE FOR THE SACRIFICES
OF OUR MILITARY.
I AM SURE THE DIGNITY WAS
AFFECTING TO THOSE FAMILIES.
>> YOU PLAYED JOHN PAUL II AND
FDR, HOWARD COSSEL AND NOW THIS
EX-CONNICKY DONOVAN WHO IS THE
STAR.
I UPON RAY IS THE STAR.
THIS ROLE HE IS SLY AND
DANGEROUS.
WHERE DID THIS COME FROM?
>> [LAUGHING].
WHERE DOES IT COME FROM?
SOMEBODY WROTE THIS TERRIBLE
CHARACTER AND I EMBODY IT.
YOU GO TO EMMY EVENTS AND
INTERACT WITH PEOPLE.
THEY ASK ME HOW DID YOU COME TO
THIS ROLE?
I SAY I DO THIS AND TALK ABOUT
THE WORK I DID AS A BOXER.
THE PHYSICALITY THE WAY I WALK.
THEN I JUST GO OUT AND I AM
MYSELF.
>> WHAT IS JON VOIGHT'S LEGACY?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO DISAPPEAR
FROM JON VOIGHT AND BE JUST A
SOURCE OF TRUTHFUL ABOVE
INSTEPPED AN ACTOR.
I HAVE A GREAT LOVE FOR MY PAST,
MY DAD, MY FAMILY.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT I HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
DURING MY CAREER.
I CAN'T WIPE THAT AWAY.
>> THROUGH YOUR WORK YOU ARE A
SOURCE OF TRUTH.